what marriage is a tough anyway it
doesn't help to be married on a reality
show and live your marriage on reality
TV you know it definitely has hurt our
relationship I will say that it's been
tough I just know that I'm unhappy and
what I quit to being unhappy is well
maybe I'm just not in love with him
anymore you know I just want to know
when did you stop loving I wasn't
prepared for that question because I
didn't really know the answer I just
knew you know I just went into it to
break up I thought you know as his wife
I owed it to us too you know reconsider
and think about it
before I made any decisions I was just
sad like it just it just felt like you
know so much work it's exhausting
exhausting in real life and it's
definitely exhausting to watch it play
out on TV and I just felt like you know
what you know just comes a point where
if it's not working like I am Cynthia he
is Peter either we fit or we don't fit
you know I am the woman that will leave
New York City and relocate with her
child a nanny to Atlanta for love okay
so with that said I think you know I get
to be that same girl who can say you
know I think it's time for me to pack up
my tent
now because now it just doesn't I just
don't feel that same peace and happiness
that I was feeling you know when we
started this journey there's a reason
why people get married and there's a
reason why they get divorced taking it
day-by-day for now I am taking a
day-by-day I am taking it day-by-day I
think Peter is a lot more optimistic
than I am I really I really really don't
know I promise you this is the only
thing that I can't answer defense
definitively is is what's gonna happen
future